(light music)
- [Narrator] Scattered
across the New Mexico desert
are buildings that look like
something from another world.
They are homes
designed to be completely self-sustained.
Generating their own electricity,
water, gas, and food.
They are the life's work of
an unconventional architect,
Mike Reynolds, who
believes homes are the key
to a better future.
- We came up with the name Earthship
because houses have to
have gas lines coming in,
sewage lines going out,
electric lines coming in,
and so these buildings provide
all of that themselves.
These buildings address
comfortable shelter,
electricity, water, sewage
treatment, garbage, and food.
- Michael Reynolds started all this
after the oil crises in the ‘70s.
Once the prices went up,
that meant everything
we had to buy just went up.
So this house is basically trying to
make us less dependent
on all these things.
- I came to Taos right after
architectural school in 1969.
This climate is super severe.
It's real hot in the summer
and it's real cold in the winters.
So it's a perfect place to test pilot
these buildings so that you see if they
can stay warm in severe conditions
and cool in severe conditions.
There are mountains of automobile tires
everywhere all over the world.
Well, why don't we make a use for tires?
- [Rowan] The tires give out
the foundation of the house
and also the structural walls.
- The tire will not rot,
termites don't eat them,
they are resilient for earthquakes.
- And at the same time
because they're packed
with earth inside, it's
going to accumulate the heat.
It's like a heat battery.
- It sucks up heat and then
it gives it back to you
when the temperature of the room drops.
- You do feel really nurtured inside
some of these houses because
inside the living space,
the temperature is the
same all year round.
Then we have plastic and glass bottles.
We cut them in half and we put
the two bottom ends together.
It means that we'll be
using much less cement
because we're using this other
material which compensates.
At the same time, it's going to let light
come in to the house.
You can do combinations of colors,
you can do mosaics.
- [Narrator] Reynolds and his team
have been sharing their
designs around the world,
developing Earthships in places of need.
- I lay in bed sometimes awake at night,
can't wait to get up the next morning
and keep doing this.
We're building, we're
drawing, we're traveling,
doing education.
I plan to keep going until I drop
but I'm already seeing,
that it doesn't matter when I drop,
there's people that are just gonna
keep doing this.